welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name
is hisham azuz welcome to a another
edition
of the graduate entry-level focus
podcast series where we interview people
who are
either early on in their recruitment
career or recruiters who actively
support
people start their career in recruitment
and
we're going to be finding out common
challenges people have
early on in their recruitment career
maybe what people would do differently
and also just talk about why we believe
recruitment should become
a career choice and not just an accident
so
really excited to be joined by emily
today and before we go into this emily
if you could introduce yourself for
those that may not know who you are and
then we will
get into the questions yeah thanks
so i'm emily i am the head of graduate
recruitment at hire group
so essentially we're a rector wreck but
i specialize in getting entry-level
candidates into recruitment so that's
something that i've been specialized in
and my entire recruitment career i've
specialized in graduates so yeah
love it and then for context you
graduated 2017
yeah right got into sales it looks like
yeah and then my third year at
university yeah
and then obviously um and then obviously
i got into
recruitment and then you've been in
recruitment now for yeah nearly what
four
four to five years now right yeah four
and a bit yeah exactly right
there and you've always supported
graduates mm-hmm
crazy okay all right cool so i'm excited
to
dive into this with you so obviously was
excited to speak to you
on this podcast was obviously you're
dealing with people all the time
every single day um who this sort of
series is focused
uh at so i guess first thing i just want
to speak to you about
is what's your journey been like like
why
did you end up in recruitment did you
want to get into recruitment and how
would you describe
your recruitment career so far so it's a
weird one for me
um i've always kind of done sales and i
found out
quite a young age that i don't know how
this like natural knack for getting
people to do
what i told them
so in my third year of university um
i went to university a little bit later
actually so i started when i was 21
and at that point i was living with an
exploited friend i had to support myself
rent to pay i wasn't in halls or
anything like that so i kind of
worked all the way through university
and and in my third year i decided to go
sell cars i don't even like cars i'm not
really into cars but i just heard that
the money was good
so yeah my third year i was working six
days a week at arnold park selling
voxels and my day off would be like a
tuesday wednesday
and voxels yeah yeah wow i still drive
my courser i get a lot
and it's economical so um yeah on my day
off i'd go to university finish up my
degree
and then in the march um i was like i'm
gonna get the best graduate job i'm
quite competitive i wanted to get the
best job i knew that
people would be looking for their
graduate jobs in like the june
um and it came to march and i was like
i'm gonna get ahead of the curve i'm
working full-time as it is i can prove i
can balance it
um and my best friend was in graduate
recruitment at celsius and she was like
oh just come and have an interview with
us we get graduate jobs i went to that
interview and
they offered me the job and i didn't
really know too much what recruitment
was
to be in that kind of stereotype but
yeah i just kind of started in
recruitment whilst finishing off my
dissertation so that was quite stressful
um and absolutely loved it like it's by
far the best i've ever done um i think
it's a great career path for grads so
i'm quite passionate about it really
yeah i love it so why don't we normally
we end it but let
let's start with this because we're
talking about your journey and then
we'll go into
i guess common advice that you find
yourself giving we'll talk about
how grads can stand out how they can
smash interviews for recruitment jobs
etc but like
let's just start with that question then
like why obviously having you're still
on the path now
and you actively encourage people to
start a career in recruitment now so
like
why do you believe it is a good like
career path for grads because obviously
as you know typically it's always
been told as an accident i do feel like
that is
changing but i think still most people
would like find recruitment by accident
or
would fall into it so like why do you
believe recruitment should definitely be
more of a career choice than just an
accident
i don't know i think it's mental like if
you actually think about what we do
all you need is a phone a laptop and a
certain skill set to make money like i
can't really claim another sector that
allows you to do that and
you know it's so entrepreneurial like
there's so many schools you can go into
and um you can kind of start your own
businesses and stuff like that within 10
years which most sectors you can't
really do
um i think you learn a really good kind
of skill set and it's fun
as well like to work every day we
actually have a proper laugh and
the earning potential the progression
like the amount of
time and energy business owners invest
into making sure that their business is
the best place to work
i don't think you get that in other
sectors um
and yeah i just think a great career
path is something i'm really really
passionate about
um so yeah i think i think
what i find so like bizarre about the
recruitment industry is like
when you find yourself working in the
industry
you're then like how did i not know
about this industry do you know what i
mean
it's crazy i don't think it's talked
about university i don't think it's
viewed as like a big prestigious route
to go down but if you look at the
earning potential and recruitment
compared to
the big four or the ones that you're
kind of trained to think is a good
career path
i'd say it's pretty like on par the
money that you make in recruitment and
and the progression and the success that
you can get so i don't know why we're
not educating these graduates or these
people that this is a really really good
career path
yeah so where else i'd love to sort of
just take this really quickly and get
your thoughts on so obviously
like we're talking about what you can
get out of a career equipment but
obviously what about what are your
thoughts on like the typical skills or
experiences professionally or personally
that
you would expect grads to experience or
get from recruitment that they probably
least expected
because they might be going into like
right i'm gonna yeah maybe
experience earning more money experience
doing sales or whatever but like
what are some of the typical things that
maybe you've experienced yourself
personally you least expect to adore
what grads could at least expect that
actually is a really positive thing
i think it depends i'm a strong believer
that there's
kind of a sector or a company for for
most
people like as long as you're hard
working so i think it would depend
sector to sector but for me personally
it's reading people like someone might
be telling you well that's great
but i'm able to almost like whether they
believe that i'm sure a lot of
recruiters will kind of relate to this
but
it's kind of being able to read like
between the lines of what people are
saying
and kind of yeah get kind of information
out of people which is not something
that i thought i would
be able to do like fully understand
people um
i think the drive as well and i think
the drive comes with
if you love your job and so yes i'm very
very driven
but i enjoy my work so taking that call
on an evening i'll do and i didn't know
i had that drive in me
that makes sense like yeah yeah a
waitress or whatever you say are you
really driven like no not really
um you know i don't want to work that
extra i want to go home but in
recruitment because i think because i
love what i do i've kind of found that
drive within me and i can put the hours
in and i can put the hard work in
so yeah i'd say drive reading people
um i guess yeah it just depends on
sector to sector because mine's very
kind of telephone heavy but other
sectors might be kind of more email
heavy or making matches or more
intricate so
i do think it depends on sector to
sector but what i did find out about
recruitment
especially as a rhetoric is that they're
so many different companies and so many
different sectors
look for different skill sets it's not
just kind of one fits all
yeah no what i love what you're saying
there is that what you're saying about
being driven but what you're really
saying there is that it
sort of it can sort of i guess
show people like what like their full
potential
or like what they're fully capable of
right uh if they're
able to like that that's just what for
me i had no idea what to do i was like
what i had job at like b and q like the
range doing this
random [ __ ] and then i started
delivering pizzas for dominoes
and then i ended up didn't like getting
a sales job but i was like commission
only and i was like oh my god i can
actually
being in the in the job where i can sort
of hopefully make more money
in line with like the work that i put in
and then like thinking of being in a job
where like i could get paid the exact
same as the person next to me and i
could be trying
110 percent more than the person next to
me would get paid the same
i was like why do i ever want to be an
environment i would ever want to be in a
job like that again
so um i love that so i guess the next
part to this then and then we'll go into
sort of practical advice and common
things that you see i'm really keen to
get your thoughts like i'm sure
obviously you're this is your world but
it seems to from what i can see
recruitment agencies are really piling
on now hiring for their own businesses
because not everyone obviously but a lot
of markets are really busy
so most recruitment agencies would love
the opportunity to
grow their own talent right with no
previous experience
so what in your view
from a recruitment business point of
view if i'm hiring for my business and i
want to track the types of people that
you
work with like what is it they actually
want i know
there'll be intricacies and there will
be nuances to individual but
holistically like
what is it the grads of today or the
entry level tandem
today actually won from a recruitment
business from an employer what are they
actually motivated by is it
the obese ib for incentives is it being
able to afford the rolex and show that
off to their mates like what actually is
it that actually
like really excites them lights their
eyes up and actually
they speak to you about like this is why
i'm gonna work for this company this is
what i feel like it's gonna give me
i think um for me a lot of the grads i
speak to really like the startup stuff i
think
historically i speak startups and
they're like oh you know we're tiny like
how can we compete with the
big corporate businesses but actually
when you sit down and speak to graduates
they love that they can get in and make
a difference and progress quicker i
think it all comes down to progression
ultimately
but um if you're a startup owner
listening to this and you're thinking
i'm not gonna be able to get
you know the best talent i think you are
i think you could easily compete with
some of the bigger companies i think
it's the bigger companies that need to
work harder
not necessarily what up so i think the
of five
um the progression 100 and the ability
on that sorry to buy end sorry
progression has been like the common
thing that people said but i just i
guess
keen to just i guess you try and peel
back the onion a bit like from your
point of view just on this like
what does that actually mean like when
people say emily i want progression like
what does that does that mean that most
peop
is it just people just want to feel like
they're moving forward and they're not
stagnating is it just because they don't
want to feel bored
in their role is it because they do want
to manage people like what actually is
it that excites them about progression
out of interest and
what does that look like to them i think
um
when you're at universities this idea is
probably relevant to grads i guess but
when you're at university you're told
you go to university finish university
and you get a graduate scheme um
a graduate scheme basically means if you
do x y and z
um you know you're going to get
promotion and a pay rise and you're
constantly working towards that next
thing and you kind of got your path
almost written out for you i guess and i
find that
as soon as i say to graduates oh you
know i've got this business in didsbury
from day one
on your desk you'll have it set in front
of you if i do x minus then i'll get a
promotion
to this if i do xbox then i'll get
promotion to this i think it's having it
so um wow and it comes with
management that comes with this it comes
with that i think everyone's different
and some people i do speak to want to
manage people and some people just want
to make money and some people like the
idea of having
a better job title that you can tell the
mom and dad about like it
it's hard to kind of say like you speak
for all graduates but
yeah it's from experience if i say to a
candidate
um from day one you'll have this all
laid out in front of you
that sparks that interest straight away
um i think it's
right it's not like you've got you know
you're somebody's favorite so
that's why you're getting that promotion
or whatever people like things to be
kind of fair
um now so i think it depends candidates
candidate but structuring it is
definitely
important and having smaller ones as
well so
i think what so on so again just dive
digging into this a bit deeper then
on the i think a common thing if i think
of the small
grain recruitment business where i
started my career at i wouldn't say that
it was that very clear and
maybe this is something that you advise
these startup grand recruitment
businesses and and having interviewed a
lot of business owners
i do feel like sometimes as a small
grain recruitment business owner you may
feel like one
sort of have that sort of doubt of like
why would people pick us over
like a bigger company sort of thing you
might be thinking about that
which can then sometimes lead to not
making the time to actually map
out what career progression looks like
because you may have the mindset of ah
we'll do that when we're a bit bigger or
we'll have a career development plan or
a clear path for people when
we've got 10 people 15 people so i guess
i'm sort of leading the question here
but like would like how important is it
then to like for
small ground recruitment business to
actually just map that out and sort of
yeah have a direct plan for people
despite how big they are
crucial like absolutely sure and i when
i go to
meetings i often help them and sit down
and map out with them we get
my pay grade but i like to kind of help
with that type of stuff and i think with
grads
and entry-level people it's having lots
of little
um progressions milestones and yeah yeah
um yeah just breaking that down instead
of like oh in
three years time you're gonna get ten
grand pay rise and it's like well that
feels so far away
and it's not competitive with the market
because if you have someone sat on their
20k base they'll play too long you get
retroactive other recruitment businesses
being like all of our business you'd be
on 25
or whatever so kind of breaking that
down and just keeping them motivated to
that next step because it's also going
to make them work harder for you
so it's going to keep you also it's
going to motivate them to want to hit
that max that next step and
put their promotion on linkedin and tell
the mum and dad and that's going to
bring them
i don't know is i think that you're
likely to get people
staying within your business and looking
elsewhere if you do implement that i
think it's crucial yeah
no i love that so before i bite it in
sorry
you said progression what else was you
gonna say sorry
you you mentioned the ibiza thing um
yeah why did i get graduates calling me
off and be like emily i want a free
tricks iv for what jobs have you got
like that doesn't happen
at all and i don't think if you're a
business owner that offers ib for
someone's going to come in and say i
really want to go to ibiza but from my
experience
um when i was a grad i'd never heard of
a work holiday before like that was so
foreign to me and that was a huge class
it wasn't the fact that i got a free
holiday it was the fact that you kind of
you hear like really serious important
business people going abroad and i kind
of resonated with that and was like oh
you know i'm gonna be really important
it's gonna be a really good job
um and it's fun and i think it's a good
way for you know bonding and
the team environment so i do think it is
important that you do implement them
because everybody else
yeah yeah i think the reason why i say
that i know i know it's like probably
cliche and i'm not and like
i had some wicked trips and i'm sure
anyone listened to i've got some great
stories to tell i think i guess the
reason why i say that is like
what i'm just trying to get from you
which you've shared with us is like that
shouldn't be like what you're leading
with
i feel like i feel like that should be
like part of your arsenal like why
what are the positives about working
here but i'm keen to find out what
companies should be leading with that
actually like resonates with young
people and what they're excited about
and it seems like it's progression
there's a clear winner but and then
actually of course you then need to
think about the other benefits that you
have them
are you offering great incentives and
these things but i think it's companies
that
think because they they instead of going
to our beef they're going to marbella or
because of
they're going to these other places that
that's why they're going to get extra
talent and that's just that's just not
the truth do you know what i mean
yeah so it's important yeah agreed for
sure so
let's talk about let's go into them like
common things that you help grads with
or talking about now how we can really
sort of help grads
land their first job in recruitment or
like smash
um their first year recruitment these
types of things so i guess
first thing from your point of view if
i'm listening to this right now and
i do want like you did you took the
initiative to try and
beat the rest of the pack of people
applying wanting to enter the industry
like
what are your like top one two three
things that you typically tell
grads or would tell grads listen to this
or people wanted to enter in the
workforce this year to like stand out
amongst the amount
large amount of applications that jobs
will be getting like what can people do
listen to this to stand out amongst
people
who also applying for the same jobs god
there's so many
um so if you're talking about like
you're watching me like prepping your cv
before you get to the interview
well i would say so if i so i okay
to drill it down a bit i guess if you if
i was like your best mate and i was like
right mean i want to get into
recruitment
but i know i'm going to be like i'm
going to be applying for jobs online
that's my strategy
but i know when i click apply there's
going to be like 100 200 other people
applying for that job
like like what can i do to stand out
so make it you know a really good cv
that's relevant to
what you're applying for so if you're
just applying for recruitment fantastic
research the skills that are needed in
recruitment and target your cv
accordingly make sure your
personal statement at the beginning is
highlighting the relevant skills that
they're looking
for you know um and i get it i would say
about
30 of the applications we get is like i
want to be in marketing or i want to do
this and it's like well
you haven't yeah that's the first thing
yeah
yeah that's really really cool yeah i
actually feel like it does need to be
highlighted
so yeah make sure that you're if you're
applying for a job that your cv is
irrelevant
because i'm not going to call you if
you're saying that you want a different
job
um so yeah um interviewing is
probably really really important
especially in recruitment because if you
think about
it and what do we do all day we screen
people we talk to people
so actually really hard one
i was just going to say let's go into
interview tips then yeah instead let's
go into interview tips then for sure
because that'd be really helpful for
people
yeah so we screen people all day we
speak to people all day so people kind
of look at graduate jobs and they see
hundreds of recruitment jobs come up and
they think oh it's gonna be really easy
job to get because there's so many of
them that it couldn't be further from
the truth
like everyone's quite fussy um
so there's loads really i think the most
important thing i get is be yourself
particularly with graduates you come out
of university you think i'm in the
business world i'm gonna have to pretend
to be this corporate robot
serious and you'll just kind of do the
same as everybody else you're never
going to stand out it's just like
you just really really be yourself and
show your personality and make sure
they're going to hire you for you
and who you are and what you can bring
to the table not what everybody else can
bring if you're
just don't be caught like overly
corporate and don't be a robot
essentially
i think that's really really important
have a laugh with them like enjoy your
interview
um so yeah um
i think questions as well so there's
some awful interview questions that i
really really don't like
um that's personal preference as in as
in people interviewing asking the
interviewer
questions questions at the end of the
interview if someone says you've got any
questions for me obviously the worst
thing you could do is say no
and make sure i tell my grads to prep
over 10 questions for every interview
they go to because you don't know you
might be interviewed by like five
different people
um and if you do make sure you remember
their names take a notepad and pen if
you've been interviewed five five people
make sure you've got their names written
down
um because that's really important but
yeah asking good questions and making
sure you're prepping questions that you
can ask every single person if you run
out of questions what advice do you have
for me
um how did you get into recruitment just
show a bit of interest
and don't ask weak questions like how
much support am i going to get you
should be like i want to be the best
recruiter i can be what's your training
program like
it's essentially the same question but
it's just us
ten times better way um you know show
ambition like you're asking questions to
show them what you're like as a person
not necessarily to get information so
like
who's your highest biller and what do
they do differently you're showing
ambition it's showing that you want to
go in there and absolutely smash it so
think about the questions that you're
going to ask and what they say about you
i think is important i love that and
then
i guess just to get really practical
again and maybe you've just gone through
them but other
other maybe pet peeves you have or
interview like things to avoid
when interviewing for recruitment jobs
out of interest that you always
make sure people avoid that
you know typically doesn't resonate with
people yeah there's a few things
um a lot of people say i want to get
into recruitment to help people
now i've been trained so some people
might like that but my
my first recruitment job was very very
old school training and we got told that
no that's not the question it's not the
answer that we're looking for because
you know go work for a charity having
worked in recruitment now i think one of
the reasons why i do work in recruitment
because i do
genuinely help graduates and people get
the job that they really really wanted
and i do find it very rewarding
and so there's a bit of a debate there i
don't know which side i'm on if i'm
completely honest i feel like i feel
like
i feel like it changes i feel like if
your lead
reason why is i want to help people
that first year recruitment is going to
be extremely even
more difficult if you're like lead
reason why is i want to help people
because when you're in that job doing it
day to day it does not feel like you're
helping people or like like you may feel
like you are and then you're
getting rejection they're frightened
center people don't want to speak to you
and like it's not it's just not that
strong i just feel like it's not strong
enough like it needs to be accompanied
with
i want to help people and also whatever
it may be to get what i mean but it
can't be like the lead and the only
thing i feel like would just
i understand why people may not like
that but i do feel like
it does change over time like you do get
rid like
for me once you do that first year and
then you're like oh my god like i'm
like i'm actually able to change
people's lives and that's proper cringy
and cliche
but it's [ __ ] true like and like
that's what gets you really excited and
it's like you know i do want to help
people
but you've had to work through that
early period of like
i'm i'm here because i've got a point to
prove i want to make good money blah
blah blah whatever
but if you're leading with it it's going
to be it's going to be hard so i do get
that
yeah so you don't not leading with i
want to help people that may not
resonate with everyone
what else do people need to avoid in
these interviews
not to avoid me personally i hate the
question
i despise it what's the best and worst
thing about working here
you're an agreement director you don't
want to have to tell them what the worst
thing about your business is who wants
to do that
like i hate it it's like my worst
fashion ever and what's the best thing
about working here
or well you know you should come there
wanting to work there do what i mean
like
i don't know i just really don't like
that question um also
stupid thing like oh what happens if i
don't hit my target why does it be
working
wrong you get sad like draw me
yeah it's just like it's how you're
going to make that other person feel
about you
like feel about you already yeah it's
just those types of questions you've all
said like what support am i going to get
the way you're asking that is like oh
what so you're already concerned around
not being able to
it's that and then it's what you and
then it's what you just said it's like
what happens if i don't hit my target
but you don't really want to be leading
with that it's more you're not yes more
about asking a similar question where
it's more like
from what i understand loads of
recruitment businesses have had to adapt
over the last 18 months so what
new things have you implemented over the
last 18 months to make i don't know some
but do you know what i mean it's like
it's yeah she's thinking about in a
different way isn't it
yeah and then the last one that i
despise if they say tell me a little bit
about yourself you're like
yeah i'm emily i'm 28. i've got a dog
auntie sister brother are you talking
for half an hour and you're thinking no
one actually cares like they're just
talking and talking and talking and
talking
so i try and tell my graduates to prep
like a 30-second elevator pitch just to
make sure that
it starts off really really strong so
you know absolutely my name is mlam
targeting money motivated works in sales
love recruitment
just that's why i'm here and just
rounding it back and keeping it relevant
opposed to going on and on and on and on
and on because
yeah i've had it before when i've was
screening a candidate you know tell me
about yourself and i'm literally like
you know drinking my coffee
is that is a hard question though isn't
it because it's like
how much they want to know where do i
stop do i like tell them like what about
when i was a child like do you know what
i mean
like it's i get what you mean so it's
good to think about how you would answer
that
yeah for sure perhaps like that is like
my first question i asked on screen in
candidates because i think you get a lot
from that like i'm not expecting
everyone to comment
on my first call and and do an elevator
pitch of course
but um i think it's a really good
question to ask um just to see how they
cope because it's kind of a little bit
of pressure at the same time isn't it
so yeah sure okay so what so we've
spoken
about interview tips things to avoid how
people can stand out
what about then um a couple of last
questions
so one i'm interested to hear your
opinion on
as you said there's loads of different
markets and sectors out there and this
is where i guess a lot of your expertise
can come in when speaking to people
you may have a better idea of like what
type of sector
could potentially be great for them with
what they've shared with you
so like how can people like when you
start
considering recruitment as a career it
can be really daunting about like okay
well what market am i going to recruit
in or
like should i go down the path of like
doing recruiting something i enjoy
whatever like what's your advice on like
if i'm going
emily like i do want to get into
recruitment but i'm actually unsure of
what
market i want to get into like what
advice do you have there
so i look a lot it's kind of different
on personality's personality so if
somebody is like
i don't know super super chatty a bit
off that they're like me then i think
like a pc market
or something like that where you are on
the phone and if their strength is just
kind of being on the phone and then i
think more of like a pc market like
i think i'd be great in construction or
they don't mean something like that
um opposed to like i'd be terrible in
like
head hunting or something that's really
really intricate um i think
it's hard it takes i don't know a lot of
time a lot of knowledge and a lot of
understanding your clients and i think
if you're a grad i'm not just saying
this to
get placements but you should definitely
use the right tourette because there's
so
many businesses in manchester apply for
recruitment business and hope it's going
to be right because
the chances are that it's not um
academics as well if somebody's super
super smart
and kind of you know research heavy and
stuff like that then
yeah more of a head hunt like intricate
market might suit like suit them
so it just depends so it's really really
hard to say but i would honestly
recommend
using a rhetoric or somebody who can
match you to certain businesses because
you might keep putting yourself into the
wrong business and getting rejected you
could end up going away and be like oh
recruitment's not for me but actually
you've been going
in the complete direction does that make
sense yeah yeah i know
i know it's quite hard i know there's a
lot of intricacies and
things i guess yeah i guess that's fair
i guess maybe
if i don't if i'm listening to this and
i don't end up speaking to someone like
you it's
being mindful of when you do speak to
them when you do interview places and
you're
meeting people and you're finding out
about the way they do things like be
mindful of
if that's gonna if you feel like that
could yeah is in line with how you want
to work or how you see yourself can
best perform and stuff like that but i
know it's it's hard
yeah it's crazy like we've got um a few
different departments like
in our business just in rec to wreck so
we've got like direct-to-level stuff in
london
and it's crazy that my job and their job
comes under the same umbrella and
recruitment because
i'm always on the phone they're never on
the phone they're in front of the
computer writing emails doing matches
and stuff like that
and it's such different skills and that
them on that team are completely
different to who i am on my team
it's just it blows my mind that that all
stuff yeah
yeah yeah i got you mean so a couple of
last things so what i want to ask you
now before i ask you the final um
question is from your point of view
thinking of some of the like the great
people that you've been involved in
in helping supporting like obviously as
i'm sure you describe it or communicate
in some way that like that first general
recruitment is
like really difficult like what common
traits or like characteristics do you
see
in grads that you place or support that
you find do really well in that first
year or
have the best chance of smashing it like
just thinking about what people need to
have in mind going into that first year
like are these people
um people that you find to be like
really responsible
and like take their own development
seriously i don't know like what comes
up for you when we think of traits and
characteristics that
great grads have or entry-level talent
have to do well in that first year
i get asked this all the time it's
really really difficult it's hard to
quantify like sometimes you'll get that
candidate and it's like
you just know something except when you
know over that song yeah
yeah and one of the first things i look
for um
because a lot of my roles aren't them
intricate head hunting roles i've got
one or two but predominantly like
tech engineering like all your kind of
as my usual recruiting businesses
um the first thing i look for is can i
sit on the phone to you for an hour i'm
not going to
but could i start on the phone shoot for
an hour and it'd not be awkward and we
have a great conversation
and that's something that i kind of look
for
also likability so business development
and getting candidates on aren't that
isn't gonna be that hard if you're
really likable and if you're kind of
instantly warmed
up person um i think likability is
really really important
um there's not really many tangibles on
a cv because there's so much good stuff
um it's not really a one-size-fits-all
but
i always kind of ask the question you
know what are your personal goals but i
think a good one
about your personal goals is to ask what
personal goal have you had in the past
that you've achieved and how did you do
that
because like if you want something are
you really willing to go after it and
work hard for it and i think that's an
important thing to look for
um and just kind of any kind of signs on
their cv or their experience where they
have had to really work hard for
something
so it's really difficult but i think
personality is definitely the biggest
thing that i go
i look for um if you've got a great
personality and people instantly warm to
you
then that's gonna make your life and
recruitment a lot easier than easier
yeah yeah all right so i just want some
like
final honest like market insights from
you basically if that's okay
so just for content so you you do what
what what um
what part of the country do you cover
manchester south manchester i don't know
yeah but you obviously you might have an
idea for your peers on the other thing
so what i just want to
know for you to finish this off then so
if i'm if i'm listening to this
i'm a grad or maybe coming into
recruitment for the first year like one
i know there there'll be a lot of
intricacies here but holistically
like what is like what salary should i
expect like starting salary what entry
level
starting salary should i expect in
manchester 202
22 okay realistic first year ota
33 depending on the company it really
does
yeah i got i did 33.
okay it's a little bit like maybe 30k to
35. 35. i've got something that's where
you're generally
will do like 50 but you're gonna have to
work really really hard really hard yeah
yeah okay
cool thank you for if you want to see
then the other thing and then
i know that this will be really varied
but again just a lot honest thoughts
like commission structures like what
we're talking
like what what so basically i guess what
what would you say
would be like if you used to speak to
someone on the phone
and they told you what their commission
structure was and you're like
oh i think that thing that's like really
like quite out of whack with like ev
like what you should be getting like
what's like a
bad commission structure would you say
oh well i'll say that
yeah yeah come on okay so the first when
i was in recruitment my first job i
didn't realize how
bad it was until i moved to higher group
yeah this is important
yeah so like i got 135 pounds of
placement
um and then how long until
throughout my career um oh wow two years
yeah
um and they were like yeah fairly big
place obviously it's grads but it's
still funny when they're like 360 deals
so like you've got the client on and
place and you've got 135 quid
no but i did so kind of some of them i
did so i did
180 then 180 but either side so i
started off as the talent and then moved
over yeah
so i'd either bring the client on and
then the other side would place or vice
versa but either
both sides would get 130.
or whatever it would be so yeah that
wasn't ideal um
so if you're getting some sort of like
because i if you're getting some sort of
per
placement and it's like 100 quid 200
quid
i guess it depends how long how long
yeah like yeah you need to like check
that but i guess it depends like
if that's like just until i don't know i
feel like
i'm trying to think what i had i feel
like i had something like that but very
quickly it then changed it was like just
at this i don't know yeah
like if somebody's put all the legwork
in and got the clients and kind of
wrote the ad and done all the work and
you just have to call people up and get
them into the first three months and
then you change onto the proper
commission structure that's fine
but i'm talking i've had three
promotions and i was still on yeah
that's yeah that's that's terrible
i think percentages um nothing below
10 if you're on like a five up to 10
commission structure
get out um you know a lot of our
businesses i've got one business that
goes up to 50
um yeah how common are thresholds
i have one yeah um so fairly modern
yeah yeah i was just curious yeah no i
have i don't mind it it depends on how
well you build but i appreciate
why people do it and yeah it's not a
massive one i think
if your threshold is above i don't know
i don't know how to say this
yeah of course this we're just you're
not saying the companies have this we're
just saying you're just saying what you
find and like you
you're in the perfect position to like
just have an honest view of like
this is subjective this is your view but
some people will have no idea
like if their commission structure is
any good that's why this is important
if you're on a basic salary of below 30k
shall we say and your
threshold is above 6k eight or six or
above i think
you know you could probably do it could
be better yeah yeah yeah i think one was
like three and a half
yeah it always stayed like that yeah
um so obviously it is salary dependent
um but yeah i think look at your
commission's choices have conversations
with people
um just to know because i didn't know
when i sat in that role
that's what i mean and i feel like most
decent recruitment companies would want
to improve that but they may have no
idea on like what good looks like
so like because i had someone missing me
the other day actually saying like we
want to improve our commission structure
and we have no idea and you
feel like you could be in a good
position to like talk about this and i
was like honestly i don't know
but like i was like tell me what yours
is and i'll probably have a good grasp
of like if it's rubbish or not
yeah i think i think what he messaged me
i was like yeah you definitely
definitely need to have a look at that
i think it was like a threshold of like
maybe five six grand or something and
then like it was ten percent
like on everything like even if you had
a lot of 40 grand a month maybe 10
of that and i was like no that could
that can't be right that's awful
um it's weird though because when you're
speaking to grads
i rarely get asked about commercial
structures obviously i would educate
them and i would say you know this is a
good one or
you know out of the three options i've
got you that's got commission structure
for this office
i mean i i will always do that but i
think for graduates coming in
even to achieve that 30k in your first
year it just feels so far away and that
commission structure yeah yeah
clearly on the forefront of their mind
like again i'm not speaking for
everybody it's just through my
experience but
it's it's other stuff that they want to
buy into it's that it's the working
environment it's the progression it's
surrounded by other people like similar
kind of demographic
as them and stuff like that that's
really really you don't i guess the
reason why i was interested to get your
thought is because you don't want to be
in that position where like you end up
doing two years of recruitment
and you do really enjoy the company but
you end up getting some recruitment
mates and you realize that your
commission
like you could have earned like just a
lot more or
do you know what i mean i think that
that's why i wanted to ask you like what
actually
looks like from your point of view
because i think yeah yeah you don't have
in that position where you're like oh
wow
wow i could have actually done even
better even though i really like working
here
yeah no for sure i think it is important
and
try and have conversations but i don't
want to like i don't believe views is
like oh selling right to rex but
honestly like if you're in recruiting in
the anger yes
huge value that you can add isn't it
yeah yeah have a conversation
um and then also if you're hiring people
make sure that you're explaining really
simply what the job is and what
recruitment is i don't know if we've
touched on this but that's really really
important
is make sure that you're educating your
entry level staff and what recruitment
is and what the job entails
because i think that's a huge
misconception
we've covered a lot thank you so much
for uh
being part of the this series i really
appreciate it i know this has been
slightly different from the other ones
but i think just loads of value in here
and insight for
business owners people wanting to hire
graduate talent and then also on the
other side as well
so emily thank you so much for for
joining me
thanks so much for